think first Olivia you are the comic-con
like this is your space yeah like a
comic-con goddess are you helping
everyone else make it to comic-con I'm
knowing if asking for advice but but I
think they do ask now show me more about
gaming yeah you guys have been doing
pretty good on your own so far
who's doing the worst though the time
yeah relative a second is going to like
just stop getting effect after a while
he just purely yeah non-stop no I'm
literally the guy like right beyond
Owens are you coming are you Sailor Moon
yeah no it's a five year old okay okay
three three quick tips for comic-con um
yourself
hahaha no one else wear wear pants that
you can they can turn into short have a
backpack and don't take everything that
free and what's in the backpack so you
can put like the actual good stuff in no
I don't think all the fries definitely
get to get loaded down with all the
proposers free you know he changed my
buttons literally yeah you got all the
good stuff
yeah your backpack open for the good
stuff have you ever cut pants into
shorts I know have you wouldn't that one
of your kissed your son is rippling
oh like a nice cargo you better not have
a pair of those right now girl awesome
jump with you no beer okay all right I
watch a lot of Ninjago because I have a
seven-year-old Oh doesn't want to mess
with him I want to hear your voices so
then I can just I could play a fact form
and totally Bend his mind because he
will lose as my own we start what am i
doing your voice my boy yeah talking I'm
like lego ninjago boy oh boy boys time
to wake up boy come
all right I've been out all night um
yeah everything's good
what do you do something I'll Reese
Reese be online Reese you're the man the
voice that you're nearing we're going
out I'm going out on a limb with this
character you close your eyes and see if
you can hear this David or Lloyd okay
here ya go
close your eyes go and go who's talking
right now who do you think oh okay all
right
thank you Michael my turn to look after
your play that's it man right on the
morning the most give me a little I mean
it's just me I play a robot so I don't
have to in any way alter my natural
revived
just me giving Oh God
is usually shouting and I don't want
shout did in it get it right now you've
got it I'm gonna conquer into Oh
actually long those people why don't you
love the jacket girl come on and it
talks down to this yeah when he's
actually talking I give that up
I don't know is carbon odd sound like on
the show got to do it I guess he does
another one right no come on you gotta
know like that doesn't no no okay KITT
we're like the like this more Gary yet
any girl I've seen them just like did
you as a parent
yeah it almost starts to like all meld
together oh my god you're like oh and
then you know they have little figures
and they're all of your houses that
bottom and yet this all hurt yeah it
hurt your feet
I just want to throw that out there more
ease down on these characters okay so
come on did you guys at all get to work
together
did anybody get to hang with anybody
else and work together we all hung
together once for a long extended
session there's like eight hours it's
like eight hours yeah it was a long
session one of the worst days of
very honorable and know you don't like
she's not therapy but listen
yeah okay yeah and and we got shooting
Silicon Valley while this is going on
did you ever like well we've been doing
saying you're right yeah we've done I
think three seasons officially entirety
until yeah G there was no Titan to me
when we started this did you ever trade
lies or anything or Joe improvise that
it's make another man president Silicon
Valley it's like an HBO show so you can
be kind of dirty good day all the world
think of a war against the rules no but
they were still dirty
thank your book working they still kept
how did you keep it there if we could
horrendous thing yeah we when we all got
together it was really fun to be worried
everyone was able to improvise they
would just give it situation we were
just all sort of being our characters in
that situation and then they will
construct themes around it it was really
cool so it's fun yeah when you record by
yourself you feel psychotic because the
only thing that separately I'm someone
who is severely mentally ill is the
microphone because you just they'll be
like gasp any other pop and then they'll
be like do it again and you go gasping
yeah call you back and then like so what
are we doing today I'm like we got to
get that we got to get in there yeah
yeah yeah I had to go back four times
for the same one mom I'm really not that
I'll go sometimes there's no one reading
with you so you're I'm having a whole
dialogue just my side it's just you at
home no help you're hearing precognitive
movie yet let me I dressed up and let's
be honest been walking around for yeah
alright so an expectation of what we
will see in this movie I think this is
going to be the best lego movie yeah
ever I don't know good lord I was in
here last year you just he was off the
chain well you know that was the best
lego movie ever
and then our movie came out and now ours
will be the trigger yeah yeah yeah Lego
Fabian can only go up and it does do you
get great Lego Batman
Batman versus Robin Oh God do you extra
Lego Batman and Robin what would that
mean for someone I was talking about but
what's the third one
with the old one oh it was funnier when
you were bashing them yeah let's do one
I just got sweat and hustle is
definitely more like gutsy and we yeah
Kumail Nanjiani murder today over there
we're waiting for you no not the fans
were down for it either though he could
that well did you think I don't know
about Legos did you get free Legos I we
had Legos yesterday and then they
survived emulation yeah because my
master builder manners when did you quit
yeah you got to now could you get the
other one I requested me this guy's kid
loves a Ninjago he's rumored I don't
have any like the only way I can talk to
leg alright you come in within geography
like hey he's a kind of kid that reasons
magazine and ties enlarge the picture
not getting broken I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm on Olivia recently on
Instagram you were doing Mariah Carey
interpretive dancing you know what here
we see you want to ask can you just
it's a lot of them it is a lot of this
crazy
hey it's more dancing than mariah has
done likely if you saw what she's been
doing late oh hell yeah
Josie shots fired
Wow um well I think it's an accurate
shot
there's some big names I go oh well she
was in Vegas for the day and she wasn't
and then she danced the next night
showing every that she really could
dance oh there was one video that went
viral of her not really dancing that
much hmm okay how do I do you hate
Monica I don't know what I'm talking
about
no no I know what you're talking about I
just didn't know you're helping me do
that whole variety at all can we keep
our legendary Lambretta so far I
interned at Fox Sports during college
when he was there getting the coffee a
couple times yeah and one of us is done
really well right Gary you're like doing
dances right here and not jealous I'm
good with don't tell me I'll see you no
choice there's not talking about you
knew exactly right when you left me
alone I left right now my design Here I
am
for some reason will you real quick go
through and tell me your character's
name though each everybody give their
characters named Cinderella Minh yes
glads just like Barbie J electricity
time fire scene ice yeah water
Garmadon evil Koko um Lloyd green the
real thing what is that was that mean
boys realize the whole point of the
movie the whole movie is trying to find
out what dream it was me to an
interpretation okay all right I'm going
to just divert for a second again
Warriors win NBA Finals you've been
hanging out I you should curry how how
does that happen has that come about
well we shouldn't we met maybe a year
year and a half or two years ago and we
just became instant friends and I love
her so much and she's one of the most
down-to-earth cool people they're like
the best couple they're just such a
great great family and I was so excited
to see them get into here and I remember
texture and the very first game was like
you guys are winning this whole thing I
mean I was like like your warrior fans
and they just and she's so sweet as
she's I mean obviously they love it so
much and such a big part of their life
and it was so fun to watch it all just
like happen how you feel that's why you
can you cover to the team well now
things just went off the rail yeah
what's your pleasure
Jefferson area Jenna psychic Oh are you
upset about hitting the Lakers I'm not
I'm here to talk about lately no I don't
you know K I'm just saying later win
psycho
thank you very I would have been crazy
if they were up 3-1 and be like repeat
god I love him gonna know me ah goodbye
I'll be super upset man are you
sorry oh how many going to got me
serious I'm going into that me apart I
know I was talking with interview is
there anything finished like you
mother's right are you gonna go out on
the floor yeah I'm gonna try to honey
may have time tomorrow my first I want
to buy some of the stuff we backpack
just ruling what your name comic-con is
independent it's okay after without
heating up your ass - oh deacon
you